the studio might want me to play her
again
and if that's the case then i'd like it
to kind of be on my terms can you
picture anyone other than margot robbie
playing harley quinn or anyone other
than kristen stewart as bella it's
common for stars to turn down roles and
most of the time it was for the best
from emma roberts to jennifer lawrence
and even beyonce these actors and
actresses careers may have gone
differently if they hadn't turned down
these major roles we made one episode
and then we were not picked up to series
before taking on the role of young
heroine katniss everdeen jennifer
lawrence was almost cast as another
popular y.a character bella swan
lawrence revealed that she auditioned
for the part of the lovelust teen but
that the role eventually went to
christian stewart despite losing the
part lawrence claims that there is no
hard feelings especially since she would
soon star in her own ya franchise with
the hunger games these movies have been
my life for so long makes you wonder if
lawrence ended up as bella would that
mean stewart could have played katniss
can't seem to make my way
fourth past this whole twilight thing
you know you'd be hard-pressed to
picture anyone other than emma stone and
ryan gosling is the leads in the
oscar-winning musical la la land believe
it or not another famous emma almost
took on the role of mia emma watson
miles teller was lined up to star as
sebastian which would have re-teamed him
with his whiplash director damian
chazelle watson eventually had to leave
the role because of scheduling conflicts
with disney's live-action beauty and the
beast i had to be where i had to be so
you know scheduling conflict-wise it
just it didn't work out while teller
left because of issues regarding his
contract in the end it was for the best
as stone would go on to win an oscar for
best actress for the role while gosling
scored a nomination for best actor he
put us together and i was like
i got this
zendaya was at one point set to star in
the controversial lifetime movie aaliyah
the princess of r b playing the late
singer the then rising star eventually
left the project due to backlash the
film received as well as the fact that
she didn't feel that the production
value was there she was later replaced
by alexandra's ship zendaya definitely
made the right choice with this one the
reason why i chose not to do the la
movie had nothing to do with the haters
scarlett johansson has played the
russian assassin turned avenger for the
last 10 years but initially another
a-list actress was going to take the
role emily blunt almost took on the role
of natasha romanov in iron man 2 but she
eventually had to turn down the role
because of scheduling conflicts with the
big budget jack black comedy gulliver's
travels what a shame i just would have
to be a great part i mean it's not
necessarily that i'm desperate to be in
a marvel movie or desperate to be in a
different mood before kristen wiig took
on the mantle of the feline supervillain
cheetah in the superhero sequel oscar
winner emma stone was the studio's first
choice to don the clause
stone eventually passed on the role
which led to director patty jenkins
ultimately going to personally select
the snl alumnus wig for the villainous
role
i never get to do stuff like this it's
so fun yeah beyonce had been attached to
the bradley cooper directed a stars born
remake for quite some time even being in
consideration when clint eastwood was
set to direct before turning the rule
down when it was announced bradley
cooper would be making his directorial
debut with the film beyonce once again
was attached to the role i know that it
is the biggest opportunity of my life
and i will work as hard as i can the
world famous superstar would then once
again decline the role due to her
increasingly busy concert schedule lady
gaga would eventually be cast in the
role too much acclaim and even was
nominated for best actress at the oscars
it's extremely humbling and i'm just
grateful to have been a part of this
experience netflix's star-studded
musical the prom almost featured the
ever-popular musician ariana grande
grande would have played the role of
alyssa a closeted high schooler who
serves as a love interest to joellen
pellman's emma grande quickly parted
ways with the ryan murphy-directed film
due to the fact that filming was set to
begin when she was planning to go on
tour she was eventually replaced by
rising broadway star ariana dubose
it's a glorious moment for our community
it's great audiences around the world
have fallen in love with margot robbie's
portrayal of dc's made of mischief
harley quinn before robbie was offered
the role the team behind suicide squad
had actually went to american horror
story star emma roberts offering her the
highly coveted role roberts ended up
passing on the project to star in the
short-lived horror comedy series scream
queens re-teaming with her american
horror story colleagues i don't fight
fair kevin hart is one of the biggest
comedy stars in the world and audiences
flock to theaters whenever he has a new
comedy so it's no wonder that disney had
initially approached him to take on the
role of the genie in their live-action
remake of aladdin the role eventually
went to another a-lister the fresh
prince himself will smith
i completely know what's going to happen
but i still thought like this is going
to be something cool amandla stenberg
got their start in stardom appearing as
rue in the hunger games but they almost
joined the cast of an even bigger
blockbuster later in their career black
panther stenberg was auditioning for the
role of t'challa's genius sister shuri
though they eventually dropped out of
the process claiming that they felt they
weren't a natural fit and that the role
should go to a darker-skinned actress
which led to leticia wright being cast
just felt like it wasn't an appropriate
place for me to apply myself zac efron
is no stranger to musicals from high
school musical to hairspray and most
recently the greatest showman the
heartthrob has proven he's got the
vocals and the moves
in fact he was initially up for the lead
role of wren in the 2011 remake of
footloose ephron eventually left the
project and was replaced by gossip girl
star chase crawford who also left the
project ultimately the role went to
professional dancer kenny wermald in his
first lead role efron claims that the
reason he left the musical remake was
because he wanted to veer away from the
kinds of roles that he had done in the
past and challenge himself with new
roles
and i don't mind that at all i love i'm
only going to do different things cyr
sharonen has quite the filmography
despite her young age appearing in
numerous oscar-nominated films from the
likes of lady bird brooklyn and the
grand budapest hotel she almost had
added being an avenger to her resume as
marvel studios and director joss whedon
were initially very interested in
casting ronin as wanda maximoff in
avenger age of ultron ronan eventually
turned down the role to star in brooklyn
while elizabeth olsen was cast though
one has to wonder how wandavision would
have looked with ronan in the lead
before shailene woodley took on the lead
role of hazel grace lancaster in the
tragic teen romance the fault in our
stars another popular young actress
almost took on the role haley steinfeld
was also up for the role of the
cancer-stricken teen but the role
eventually went to woodley
i always say this but nothing's
guaranteed and it's also fleeting so
just appreciate every single moment tom
hardy was initially set to play the
beloved rock and roll artist elton john
in the musical biopic rocket man hardy
was eventually replaced by kingsman star
taran eagerton as hardy was viewed as
too old to play the musician on top of
that hardy would have only lip-synched
the film's soundtrack versus eagerton
who provided his own vocals kind of
trying to absorb as much
elton john-ness as i can
before bill skarsgard donned the clown
makeup and spooked audiences as
pennywise another young actor was
initially attached to the role will
poulter was initially cast as the evil
clown even winning the role over older
veteran performers like mark rylance
hugo weaving and ben mendelsohn poulter
eventually left the project once
fukunaga departed the director's chair
and was replaced by andy muschietti as
the new director wanted a fresh slate to
work off of
while it's definitely fun to think about
how these different films would have
been with these stars in the roles in
most cases things worked out in the end
for both stars is there an actor or
actress you would have liked to see in
one of these roles